the traditionally male-dominated sport
of wrestling has often excluded women so
this morning we're going to introduce
you to a group of women who are stepping
inside the ring not just to entertain
but to overcome personal challenges they
are the superheroes of wow what does
that stand for women of wrestling wow
get it and they include a professional
bodybuilder turned single mom a
student-athlete scarred by bullying and
a veteran who served in afghanistan cbs
saturday morning co-host danny jacobson
shows us the empowering stories of wow
[Applause]
growing up in minnesota amberly shaw
always knew she wanted to be a
professional athlete the former
synchronized swimmer and boxer known as
candy crush in the ring says she found
wrestling after overtraining and her
struggle with depression dashed her
olympic dreams wrestling
is the biggest challenge that i've
come to find so far what drew you to
wow wrestling specifically the fact that
there was a platform of all women
testing our strength against each other
and lifting each other up that was like
a no-brainer for me for adona paul's
foxy fierce it's all about glam and
grace realizing that
strength and femininity can coexist like
that was the biggest thing and they lock
up in the center of the ring
strength and femininity aren't just
found on the mat when they climb up on
the ropes i'm like i'm out there
behind the scenes is jeannie buss the
owner of wow and the co-owner of the los
angeles lakers what was important to me
was to invest my personal funds in
women's sports but the business side of
me said
what business would be sustainable that
we could create something that would
last for decades and wrestling kind of
checked all those boxes
[Music]
as we get going it was wow creator david
mclean a lifelong female wrestling fan
and the original founder of gorgeous
ladies of wrestling or glow who
convinced bus his longtime friend that
she would love it as well i thought it
was going to be jello wrestling or mud
wrestling i went to a show as soon as i
saw it
it all made sense to me and i became a
fan this is decades for you of wanting
to promote women's wrestling well since
glow which i started air this is 36 year
journey to get it on national tv they've
given the women wrestlers their own
worldwide platform it's never been done
before
retired wwe wrestling champion aj mendez
is an executive producer and provides
wow's color commentary what was it like
to wrestle as a woman
in the last decade or so
wow it was
really fascinating to watch
these superheroes that i looked up to
have to contend with this time that had
things like brawn panties matches and
stuff that just didn't wasn't something
i ever felt like i would be comfortable
doing and so my goal getting into it was
to take all the wonderful parts of it
and change the canvas and really just
make it something different what was
different about wow when you started to
find out about it was the fact that it
was all women's federation and all
women's company
what can you show me that maybe i can
learn a little of let's start off with
running the ropes flying against the
ropes coach went for a close line school
boy roll up there you go right he's like
kicking like a rocket but okay for
someone who looks at this and says well
those women aren't really
doing anything there that's it's fake
what do you say it's not fake you have
to be an athlete
you have to be fearless you have to be a
performer to get into that rank you
might feel this tomorrow bruises across
our backs we've had concussions broken
legs arms our workers come up bills
pretty high this year
for mendez it's not just about the hard
knocks people are going to fall in love
with not only these characters in the
ring but their inspiring backstories
they all come from walks of life that
are so different and it just makes you
fall in love with them as people
and then you root for them as
superheroes what i like about wow is
it's women fighting their own battles
and i think that's the message that i
want young women to hear is that it's
okay to you know stand up for what you
believe in and be passionate about it
thank you for teaching yourself
thank you
halfway across the ring another arm drag
got her down now into the arm
i did have are we losing you to wrestle
no no i do not have that kind of
athleticism anymore i did have bruises
though across my back but that's the
point they are athletes they are
athletes i know people talk about
wrestling all the time we mentioned in
the piece it's scripted you may know the
outcome of what's going to happen but
those moves and jumping off of in that
ring you're really doing these moves
nate you know this is a real fall these
are real falls and the backgrounds of
most of these women that are wrestling
is an athletic background that's awesome
incredible dana thank you very much it's
a great piece wow women of wrestling
premieres in syndication this weekend
and is distributed by paramount global
which of course is owned by cbs speaking
of